Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you for being present.
Happy Women's Day to all the ladies in
the audience and it is a pleasure and an
honor being here at Google.
It was always on the 25th of
December that my late father,
Orlando used to recite the exact same
story year in and year out to my elder
brother, Giovanni and myself. It
wasn't one of his own stories.
It didn't stem from his own experiences,
but it was a story that was relayed to
him by a former mentor of his doctor
Rossi. When my father used to work
at the Cypress Embassy in London.
The story was about a former under
secretary of defense and that former under
secretary of defense was invited for
the second year running at the same
conference
as he took up the podium.
He was holding a Styrofoam Cup with
coffin in his hand and before he started
speaking he went off
script, took a sip, smiled,
turned,
looked at the audience and said,
I want to talk to you
about the Styrofoam Cup.
Last year I was the
undersecretary of defense.
I flew here,
business class,
a limousine was waiting for me at
the airport to drive me to my hotel.
They already checked me in the next day
there was another limousine waiting to
bring me to this venue.
They escorted me to the green room and
the green room is the room where all
speakers meet and prepare before they
take the stage and when I asked for
something to drink,
they brought me coffee in a ceramic cup.
This year I'm no longer the
under secretary of defense.
I came,
I flew economy class.
I took a taxi from the airport
all the way to my hotel.
I checked myself in
and it took 15 minutes.
The next day I took another taxi to come
to this venue and because I couldn't
remember where the green room was,
I asked them to escort me and they
gave me or directions how to get there.
Then I asked for something to drink and
they showed me the vending machine and
they said, take a surf on cup and
serve yourself. Whatever you like.
He turns,
looks at the audience and says,
we all deserve a Styrofoam Cup.
The Ceramic Cup was never meant for us.
It was meant for the position
that I was holding at the time.
So as you gained fame,
as you gain fortunate
positions or possessions,
people will open up doors for you.
They wouldn't refer to
you as Sir and Madam.
They would bring gifts and when
you ask for something to drink,
they will bring your coffee
or your tea in a ceramic cup.
But because time doesn't stand still,
we all deserve a Styrofoam Cup
and I'm being former under secretary of
defense found out the hard way we sh two
should be alerted to the fact and to
the possibility that we might not be our
current position or our positions.
Who we really are.
As today's title suggests,
which is finding your inner campus,
is that internal camp has,
when you strip away positions or
positions that will guide you through
challenging and difficult
moments in business and in life.
Today,
my dear friends,
I will relay five personal stories and
each story carries a valuable lesson.
That's the lessons that power my internal
campus and helped me navigate through
the professional and the personal world.
I hope,
but by the end of the speech,
the same stories and the
underlying messages from
these stories will help power
your internal campus and help
you navigate better in your life.
So they make the road more smooth in
order to reach for that elusive word,
which is called success.
Three disclaimers to make.
Each and every lesson starts with a
letter h as you will see from each story.
Second disclaimer,
there are no powerpoints.
Unlike 95% of my keynote speaking,
there are no powerpoints because I do
not believe that there slide can depict
interlock campuses and values as well
as a vivid story which carries an
underlying message. And
disclaimer, number three,
the law.
The third story,
which happened 13 years ago in 2006
I've never ever before set this story in
front of a professional audience.
I only one message,
I only once mentioned this story
and that was on the 9th of October,
2018 as I was lecturing at University
College London in front of 300 students.
So let's begin and let me take you
back to 1997 that was the year that I
completed my studies
in the United Kingdom.
I've done my Ba and my master's degree
and like any good Cypriot boy who has a
flourishing business,
I went back to the island,
back to Cypress to work
for the family business,
all newcomers at our family business,
which was called variety
is still called variety.
We deal with catering equipment and
tabletop supplies for the Horeca industry.
The Horeca industry is hotels,
restaurants and catering.
Institutions had to go through an
induction course and that induction course
started from my late father's office
and I too had to go
through the same procedure.
That was what I called my phd degree only.
It didn't last five years.
It lasted five minutes.
My father gave me two valuable pieces
of advice for the first piece of advice.
My father took a pencil and he
took a sharpener and he said,
Michael,
yeah,
I've sharpened your edge.
I paid.
You are lucky enough and
I paid for your tuition,
but if you leave a pencil
standing on its own,
it will fall.
Go out their son and find the
hunt that will keep you standing.
The handed we'll keep you standing was
an analogy for the mentors in my life,
for the trusted advisors,
the likes of your former colleague McCally
Solo Montez who was escorting me here,
all the mistakes that I've done in my
life and all the failures that they've
encountered. Because as the
saying goes, when you lose,
don't lose the lesson
and I owe a very big thank you to all
the people who turned me down and all
those who believed in me to hire me.
And as I was making my way
out of my father's office,
he gave me the second piece
of advice. He said, son,
I see something in you.
My feeling is you will do well in
life 10 15 years down the road.
And when you do well,
when you gain positions and possessions,
if for any reason you think
that there is one person,
then you don't need them because you
either outgrown them or get in a better
position.
That's the day.
And I as an experienced professional,
young professional,
I rush to fill in the sentence and I said,
that's the day that I made it,
that he said, no, that's the
day that you lost it all sir.
So the first stage in our first story,
my dear friends is age for being humble.
Understanding that as you rise up the
hierarchy ladder as you taste success,
always remain humble
because we are not our current successes.
We are not our trophies,
we are not our positions or our positions.
Which leads me to the second story that
happened in 1998 I was one year into the
family business
and Lo and behold,
the company that my dad
told me to take care of,
which was Carlisle food service products.
It's the tumblers where you have your
juice here at Google of like food service
products.
We want the first European award.
So the Americans taller to fly all the
way to shallow together with my brother,
all expenses paid to get an award.
And we were lucky because there were
seven days of celebrations and on the last
day,
Jeffrey Gitomer,
one of the best sales
consultants in the United States,
came to speak to us for
all those who know me.
I cannot stand still for 10 minutes.
I stayed live at that on my
chair for six consecutive hours.
As soon as Jeffrey Gitomer finished
his talk, I ran up to him and I said,
Mr Gitomer, congratulations.
How can I become like user?
And he turned, he looked at me and
said, it's easy and it's difficult.
And as I say, period, I said, what's easy
is that study on your chosen topic,
whichever topic of that is
for two hours every day except weekends.
In five years,
you'll be recognized in your
country in 10 years worldwide.
I said, sir, I'll start
today. I bought his books.
At the time he had only two books.
The Sales Bible and customer
satisfaction is worthless.
Customer loyalty is priceless.
I even bought his cassettes,
not DVDs, not cds,
not USBS,
but cassettes.
And I was listening to Jeffrey
Gitomer's cassettes in my car,
which was sales messages coming out,
driving from one town
of Cyprus to the next,
promoting Caroline food service products
and all the other products that we had
that variety, and I was weeping in
my car, listening to the messages,
and I have a feeling that people looking
from the outside thought that I was
going to a funeral.
I still remember my favorite tape,
my favorite cassette.
It was one or 1.5 rules for success.
Let me tell you my
favorite rule for success.
It was the one oh 1.5 you're given a
bucket of water in a bucket of cement.
You can either build a stepping stone
towards success or a stumbling block.
The choice is yours,
and he was right.
Even the great author,
Malcolm Gladwell in his book outliers,
he said the exact same thing.
He popularized the notion that wasn't his,
but it was the 10,000 hours.
Malcolm Gladwell said that if
you want to achieve something,
you need to put those 10,000 hours in.
Even the Beatles were known for seven
consecutive years as they played music in
what was eastern Germany at the time
and it was after they hit that mark,
the 10,000 hour mark that people
started to recognize them.
Even great criminals,
as it says in the book,
need 10,000 hours to perfect their craft.
So my dear friends,
the second age is age for hard work.
I know you work at a technology company
and I know that intelligent work is also
important,
but hard work takes precedence
over intelligence work.
I guess what I'm saying to you is
sacrificed something today so you can gain
something better tomorrow,
which leads us to the third story,
which I've never before said in front of
a professional audience so you can cut
the camera now.
I'm joking.
2006 as a good Cypriot boy who was working
at the family business getting a bit
older.
By the way,
I am 46 even though I look
45 just for your information,
it was time to get married.
700,000 inhabitants on
the island of Cyprus.
We invited 4,000 to the wedding.
That was almost 1%
and the night before the wedding I found
out that my wife was cheating on me.
Yes, I know you say such a good
looking guy and she's cheating on him.
Can you believe that?
I had the same feeling.
So what did I do? I had to think for a
while and then I called everything off.
My mother was crying.
My late grandmother was hysterical.
What will happen to their family name?
What will happen to our image?
What will happen to your image? What
would happen my life? I told them
the only person who hasn't spoken like
always and waited and waited was my dad.
So he comes up to me, he says,
Michael, let's go to the front veranda.
The Front Veranda in my parents' home
was where the bad news were delivered.
The back veranda was where
the good news were delivered.
So I go to the front veranda.
He puts his hand on my
shoulders and he says, son,
you have guts.
Actually the word he was wasn't guts,
but for this speech at Google,
it's guts.
When I die,
he continued on.
I'm very happy and I will die peacefully
knowing that I can leave the company to
your brother,
Giovanni,
who has the wisdom and the patients
and also to you son who has guts.
So my dear friends,
the third age
is age for honesty and I'm not talking
about honesty from the other person
because you cannot control that.
It's being honest with yourself
to take the hard decisions.
Even if he'd paints you at the time
that you are taking those decisions
and we move on to the fourth story.
One year after not
proceeding with a wedding,
2007 now I had to find the guts to go
tell my dad that I wanted to leave the
company and pursue what you see
me now doing, giving keynotes,
training, development and
consulting. I go up to my dad.
I explained what I wanted to do. He
says, son, let's go to the front veranda.
We go to the front veranda. He
said, Michael, you can go your way.
I'm sure you will succeed, but if
you leave the, they will close down.
He bought himself 1,100 days.
I stayed at the family
business for another three
years and when the time passed
I went back. My father was a
true gentleman. He said, son,
you will do very well, but I would like
to give you some advice, go your own way,
but I would like to give you some advice.
This is where the fourth age comes in.
Always be helpful,
deliver value first or deliver value
without expecting anything in return.
And he gave me two pieces of
advice that I will never forget.
The first piece of advice was that when
you meet prospects and they ask you to
give quotations,
never merely right accommodation,
right self help book,
give them so much value that
they can see their vision,
give them so much material and
value so they can bring it to life.
If they decide to come with you,
your price will see minute.
If they opt to go with your competitors,
at least you have built a stepping
stone towards their success.
And my father was right and I still do it.
Up until today.
Even recently when a company from New
York contacted me to do a cultural
enhancement project,
which involves strengthening the team
and it had a 360 degree evaluation,
which means that those managers were
evaluated by the top management,
by their peers, by their
subordinates, and by customers.
I didn't just write a quotation,
I even sent a five page
pdf with all the questions,
everything that I was intending to ask.
And if I don't get the job,
I still know that I added
value to that company.
And if I do get the job,
they can come back and alter
some questions, change some.
And even giving me some feedback.
What my father was telling me is be
a trusted advisor, not a salesperson.
Yeah.
And I guess what I'm telling
you is transform your
thinking from what can I get
from you too.
How can I serve you?
And the second piece of advice he
gave me that day was that Michael,
you will never be the
smartest person in the room.
And he and my dad had foresight.
Even though he died in 19 months ago,
he never knew I was coming to Google.
So this guy had foresight and it's true,
my dear friends,
even if you are wanting a million
in a 7 billion population,
there are another 7,000
people exactly like you.
Why should they hire you?
Recently I was at singularity university.
I took a course there and
they have the same philosophy.
They were telling us that engineers,
the brightest minds,
scientists,
we're trying to fault protein three
dimensionally and they were trying for 15
years nonstop and they never managed it.
They all pent up,
they open sourced it and in 10 days only
a wife from the Midwest folded protein.
So the experts are the known experts,
the experts sometimes or
outside your organization.
And it is not a coincidence that
in the book of how Google Works,
it says on page 175 default to open.
So have you kind of not be the
smartest person in the room.
You can be something else.
In my case,
I opted to be the prom test and I have
a rule. If you go onto my website,
you will see that I reply back to my
messages with the rule seven seven seven I
reply back in seven seconds.
If I'm not doing anything,
I reply immediately in seven minutes.
If I'm doing something,
I want to finish it and then
reply or in seven hours,
which is the duration of a workshop,
I finished the workshop
and then I reply back.
I'm not telling you to do
that within this framework,
but expanded if you like
to 14 1414 or 21 seconds,
21 minutes or 10 to one hours,
but refrain from staying
at the 24 hour rule,
which was invented when
there were telephones,
plaque on the wall and not smart devices.
And when they were at that time,
people were more backward.
So my dear friends,
the fourth age is to be helpful,
which leads us to the fifth and final age.
And for this story,
I need to take you to nine 11 2011 that
was the day that I married the woman.
Of My dreams.
The lady that puts a smile on a daily
face on a daily per day on my parallel in
my face. And that's Christine.
And on the 28th of January,
2013 she delivered the greatest present
in our lives and that's our six year old
Rolando who wanted to accompany me on
this trip to meet the people behind his
favorite platform.
And that is youtube because thanks to you,
he observes, he meticulously
observes Christiana, Ronaldo,
soccer Mousse on a daily,
sorry, hourly basis.
So when we're going to get
married with Christine,
Christine went to your grandfather
who passed away recently,
who was married to his childhood
sweetheart for 68 years.
And she asked for advice
for a happy marriage and her
grandfather was very happy
to give that advice.
I don't know,
maybe he was worried that I would
walk away from this wedding as well.
And he said to her,
Christine,
do you know what's the secret to
a happy and a longterm wedding?
And Christine said, what's the
secret grandfather? He said,
give 100% to your spouse
and expect zero in return.
If your husband to be gives
100% and expect zero in return,
then you increase your chances
of having a happy wedding.
Think about it, my friends. It also
applies to all the other agents.
Give 100% of your marriage or to your
relationships and expect zero in return.
Give 100% to hard work
and intelligence work.
Be 100% honest first and
foremost with yourselves.
Even if he'd paints you at the
time you take the decision,
take it if you are wrong at
the immediate and apologize,
be 100% helpful by offering
value to others first
and be 100% humble.
Not because you will need someone
further down the line in your career,
but because it is the right thing to do.
So if you're wondering by now,
what's the fifth h,
the fifth h is h for heart.
Opening your heart and pour your heart
in everything and anything that you do
because it's only in this way that
you can move away from positions and
possessions and you move
closer to your true north.
And by true north,
I mean that internal compass that is
helping you to navigate through life after
all my dear friends.
It is that campus that represents who
you are as human beings at your deepest
level.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
thank you very much for
being here today with us.
Punish and I live at Toka doctors my
heart and I think you represented few of
the values we have in the company.
Like put the user first, be Humvee,
take risks. So, um, it's nice
remembering again and again.
I have few questions, uh, one then
my first question is about mentors.
Do you want to tell us who were your
few of your mentors along the way?
And My, my question is how
do you find the minders?
Is it something that comes into
your life or you seek for them?
Okay, excellent question. Uh,
how many mentors and
mentors do not have age?
If I'm going to be giving
a speech on technology, uh,
I rush to find younger people,
older people. It depends.
The people who are well versed.
My father was my first ever mentor.
I had mentors from my university days,
my college professors.
I even meet people on the road,
which I keep in touch always.
But you cannot find a mentor if you're
not ready to receive a mentor in your
life and to receive advice.
And uh,
I hope I have answered
your question this way.
Definitely. And can I ask,
it seems like the father,
the model in your life I eat
really played important role in Eh,
have you kept, I don't know, he's wisdom
in one sentence maybe or you know,
something you want to
share with us about this?
It seems like a very
pretty sure relationship.
It was a very precious relationship.
My father died on the 22nd of August,
2017 and the time at that,
the time that he died,
he was wearing kiss variety tee shirt,
which said customer service first.
So my father always believed that you
should serve your customer and that
customer is also the internal customer
and the way you treat your internal
customers is the way that your internal
customers will serve your external
customers.
So at the end of the day,
my father wasn't focused on
the price of the products.
He wasn't focused so much on the quality,
even though he believed in quality.
That's why we imported
a lot of German things,
but he believed in people and he believed
in helping people give first and then
you will receive.
So awesome for my side. Thank you very
much for this inspiring speech. Um,
in your second story,
you were talking about the advice you
got to follow to practice two hours of a
certain topic to become very good at
it. And you immediately said, okay,
I want to,
I'm going to start today.
I know exactly what this
topic is now in my situation.
I'm 30 years old now, 29 actually like me,
46 45 exactly. Um, I don't know yet,
which is the precise topic
that I want to focus on.
That drives me for the next 15 years.
And I also believe that this is
kind of an generational thing.
So what advice would you give to us
to find this topic where you have your
passion and the topic that that follows
you and the drives that basically drives
to the next 10 to 15 years?
I was 20 and that's a great question.
By the way,
I was 29 years old when
I found my passion.
When I saw Jeffrey Gitomer on stage,
I was mesmerized.
I went up to him and I asked him before
that I was working for the family
business and even though I
was enjoying it very much,
I felt it like you're filling it now.
I might be this or something else.
What I will say to you is whatever
you're doing now, give it your best.
As Muhammad Ali once said, if you're
shipping, if you're sweeping the floors,
sweep it to the best of your abilities.
Give it your best because
somebody is watching.
My late father always told me to
keep a note for everyone I meet.
What did I like?
What I didn't like,
because even I'm not
saying about your manager,
but even if your manager
doesn't appreciate what you
do, which is not the case,
but I'm just saying it.
So why are you laughing guys?
Somebody else is watching and whilst
you're doing what you're doing to the best
of your abilities, an
opportunity, we'll knock the door.
So be concerned. Shoes, do what you
do. Continue being knowledgeable,
put in those hours in
what you're doing now.
But you have to be honest with yourself.
If this doesn't inspire you,
you need to take the painful
decision and do something else.
And I'm not only talking
about relationships,
I wanted to ask,
you mentioned that you had kind of
understood three years before you left the
company,
that you wanted to change career paths.
So how did you find the courage to
actually leave after three years and just,
um,
go off and do your own thing?
If, if that's scared, it means
that I had the courage. Yes.
Then I believed I was preparing myself
for 10 years to find the courage to go
and do what I'm doing. And from the
day that I decided to go on my own,
I had to believe in myself. First
and foremost. I took my, uh,
my father's advice on board
and I was adamant, even though,
and I will tell you when I went for my
first Gig and they asked me, Michael,
how much do you charge
for a speech at that time?
At that time it was 1,500 Cypress pounds.
And the guy said,
excuse me,
1,500 pounds for a one hour speech.
Do you know how much your competitors
are charging? And he told me two names,
which had 30 years of experience
and they were charging 500 lbs.
Why should I pay you 1,500 pounds
and you don't even have experience?
And I said, sir, I was preparing for
10 years and if you don't like it,
I will give you your money back.
And he threw me out of the office,
but the next year somebody
else believed in me.
I kept the 1,500 ceiling
and they gave me a chance.
It went on to youtube.
We just don't think you know which
company by Google and thanks to Google,
I commanded my pricing and thanks to
their performance on stage because my
father told me,
if you're going on your own son,
don't put your prices low. Because
if you are very good at what you do,
it will never go up high. It all,
it will take 10 years to go up here.
Put your prices high,
deliver more value than expected.
You'll get a lot of rejections,
but you'll get a chance eventually.
Any of you are wondering
where will you find the money?
You can do two jobs until you find
the money to go for your dream.
So you're talking about really believing
in yourself and continuing on as well.
Training yourself and learning and
educating yourself and then going for it.
Yes, but I'm a be a
little bit against, uh,
the secret and it's philosophy
that think about it, it will come.
Think about no working can,
it will come put on,
put in those hours and it will come and
always keep your breach assault pen.
My late father used to tell me,
oh, we send a Christmas card.
At that time they were sending Christmas
cards, but always send a Christmas card.
Always connect with the people
that you meet on the road
because your network will determine
your net worth at the end of the day,
not only your abilities.
And I have one more
question if that's okay.
He spoke about the turn ours off yourself.
So if you do not mind speaking
to us about that a bit more,
I will speak about my true north
beyond possessions,
beyond positions.
I agree with my father that you need to
be humble because what else is there to
be and uh,
I find my true north when I hugged my
son or when I'm over with my wife and I
think what,
what powers everything is the word trust.
If you trust people who are in your life,
you have less tension and more trust to
go forward and do what you need to do.
You even have allies within your company,
within your relationship,
inside your flood or inside your house.
You need allies because no man or woman
is an island. You cannot do it alone.
So I have one more question.
How do we learn and
navigate around failures?
I also said before that when you lose,
don't lose the lesson.
If failure is a chance to understand.
For me,
when I used to work at the variety
of family business, I always asked,
where did you find us? For you guys?
You know, where did they find you?
It's called Google ad words and the rest.
But I w I used to ask and when I fail
at some people, which, what is failure?
If you stand up, you're
still standing. Uh,
you need to ask what went
wrong. Contemplate, think,
look at your offer again.
Uh, talk to people,
even to the people who consider
you in inverted commas, failure.
So the best way is asking like you,
like the Greek contingency is placing
the questions. More questions.
Questions are very important.
You judge a man or a woman or a person
by the quality of their questions,
not by the quality of their answers.
That's how you deal with
failure with lots of questions.
Um, thank you very much for the speech.
I was focusing on the um, the part,
your rule of the seven,
seven, seven and also the,
the 10,000 hours that you put in.
Um,
I mean you were working full
time for the family business.
On top of that you put in 10,000 hours
and now you traveling around the world
giving speeches and you still reply
by like seven, seven, seven. Um,
w how would he do that?
You're contested tonight if
you like. Yes, I fly Emirates.
That is wifi connection.
If I'm going transatlantic,
yes I do it because
if you're a prompt, people attributed
more things to you that you are reliable,
that you are dependable, that you
are the one they should work with.
And it's also a
differentiator. It's zone. Uh,
Marilyn asked me how do
you deal with failures?
I also should turn the
question on its head.
How do you deal with success?
I ask why beat the American
Pni why did Microsoft hire me?
I asked them and you know,
what's the answer I get?
Most of the Times it's not because you
are the best. Because I said earlier,
if you're one in a million
in a 7 billion population,
then another 7,000 people like you,
which they're very good in,
it might have a lower price.
90% told me because your prompt Michael,
because you are the liable because we
were in a hurry to set it up and I knew I
could count on you.
There are other things,
of course you shouldn't stand up here
and talk about fear is that you don't
believe in,
you shouldn't talk about others people's
stories except if that's an example
that you want twain for
to be truthful and the rest.
So I do it because it's also in my
favor because most people won't do it.
Imagine if somebody walks into your
house and you don't greet them because
you're busy.
It's impolite.
Somebody is walking into your electronic
house and they're knocking the door.
Thank you very much for the
speech. Mr [inaudible]. Um,
how would you define success?
Excellent question.
That's why I used the
word elusive for success.
It cannot be defined and it cannot
be so broad to include all of us.
Success is a different thing
for every different person.
If you ask me what success success is,
Christine and Rolando,
success for me is to live by the values
that my father instilled in me and my
mother.
Of course,
success is to wake up in the morning
and be happy doing what you're doing,
love what you're doing and if you're
not happy with it, I'm not saying quit,
but find a way to be happy doing it
and be honest enough if you are not,
if it's after six years,
it really pains.
You find the strength to move on that
success because some people tell me,
my colleague, you are a freelancer,
sometimes you might not work as hard. No,
I work hard to see a vision and to go
after that vision with no guarantees.
So for me that was success. For
you, it might be something else,
but it's elusive as they say.
In theater
you got as good as your last performance
and in my job you are as good as your
last speech or training session.
I want to talk a little bit
about your public speaking career and
acknowledge that about half the people in
the Google double office, um, don't
have English as their first language.
So it's a challenge to speak,
but even more so when English
is not your first language.
So can you tell us a little bit about
how you ramped up your communication
skills? How do you practice?
What are your tips?
Excellent. Very good. Because
we are also addressing this one,
the online program that is coming out
there was once a great football
player by the name of Malenka spoiler.
It's used to play for my
team in Cyprus or Poland.
Malenka was a very talented player,
extremely talented.
He never played in Europe.
He never played in the big
league because he was very slow.
And he gave me a piece of
advice. If you're a slow
player, passes the ball faster,
the ball travels much faster. And
if you dribble, so if you, if you,
if you are not a native speaker,
it's not the fancy words.
Keep it short, keep it simple.
And practice, practice,
practice,
practice.
Yeah,
perfect. Practice makes perfect.
So try it again and keep it simple.
Even with my mentees, when they come
for coaching sessions one on one, you,
even if that is even if their,
if their native language is English,
I always tell them, keep
it short. Keep it simple.
They gave me 45 minutes, one hour
to speak. I spoke 30 minutes.
You shouldn't be keeping you too long
if the people get the juice of what you
want to say, it's not the
fancy words and think about it,
which is your favorite politician.
My feeling is,
is not someone who uses language
that you can not resonate with,
all understand,
but it's someone who speaks to your heart.
Keep it short.
Keep it simple and practice.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
It was a pleasure.
[inaudible].